Ahsoka Tano's appearance in the
Mandalorian is set up in a way that
leads viewers to believe she will be the
one who will train grogu however after
spending a few days with him and seeing
how he interacts with his surrogate
father Ahsoka instead offers a vague
promise that another Jedi will reach out
and offer to take grogu as a Padawan
although that ends up being Luke
Skywalker Ahsoka was originally the one
the Mandalorian crater John Favreau
wanted as grogu's mentor
Dave filoni had to put his foot down on
this plan though he revealed to Empire
magazine I was telling John that as much
as I wanted to have Ahsoka in the show
she can't take this kid on that's just
not what I have planned Ahsoka picks up
after the finale of Star Wars Rebels
with the last scenes of the Animated
Series being recreated in live action
given that it was impossible for Ahsoka
to take on grogu's training and continue
her own personal mission
dealing with the aftermath of facing
Vader Grand Admiral thrawn's looming
Ascent to power and Ezra's disappearance
storylines that will continue in the
upcoming series